[Music]
Alexis you're still a child and have no
idea how much you'll enjoy laughing at
that photo of you or the later hoes and
when you're older don't throw a fit your
mother and oma they really like it you
know how much you love mangos
well you're surrounded by a small family
with a simple life who loves you more
than you love mangos they will give you
confidence your dad won't recognize the
Brooklyn neighborhood you grew up in
when you take him back to four green
decades later to fulfill your parents
dream of being able to afford to live in
Brooklyn Heights you'll buy an apartment
there though you'll end up living in
Florida and no not Disney World
[Music]
you late leaving New York City for the
suburbs of Baltimore but know that your
parents are just doing what they think
is best for you and your education with
their limited means turns out they're
right you'll be bored but you'll channel
that boredom into video games and then
computers and eventually programming
which is going to be really helpful for
later on in life you'll have to correct
people who don't believe your name is
Alexis all of your life and you'll learn
to love it
you're making the right choice when you
walk into the history department first
semester of your first year the
University of Virginia to declare your
major shocking the department head at
how early you commit trust your
instincts when you walk out of the LSAT
without finishing it in order to go to
the Waffle House you're making the right
choice that decision is gonna change
your life because they're between those
syrupy bytes of waffles you're gonna
realize that you're meant to be an
entrepreneur not a lawyer all those jobs
you had growing up from compusa sales
guy to pizza cook are gonna help you
tremendously as the co-founder of Reddit
but nothing could prepare you for your
mom getting diagnosed with terminal
brain cancer just a few months after
graduating from college and starting
your company you're gonna wish you can
remember all the little details her
accented voice her breath is laughter
the intensity of her hugs and the charm
of her high fives she'll show you what
it means to be truly courageous and
selfless and you'll spend the rest of
your life working to make her sacrifices
worth it let her hug and kiss you in
public it doesn't make you any less
tough and it means everything to her and
you'll understand when you're a father
you've got your own little shots
[Music]
speaking of dad he'll show you what it
means to be a man he spent most of your
childhood working late nights in order
to provide for the family
and he'll support his wife throughout it
all and advocate through every chemo
treatment in Iraq for her amidst all the
uncertainty until the end the whole
ordeal gives you a wisdom at a young age
to realize what matters in life are the
people and experiences not things one
acquires along the way I am from the
initialize capital I am so happy to see
so many of you redditors actually
managed to graduate you'll have success
in business but they'll be plenty of
setbacks and surprises trust your
instincts when it comes to people purge
toxic relationships and spend time with
the people who inspire you to be better
start now in fact you'll be meeting some
of your lifelong friends in elementary
school very soon
this is random but bear with me you'll
do a class assignment in the fourth
grade where you'll share just how much
you hate tennis that's fine for now but
promise me you'll keep an open mind
later in life
[Music]
you'll eventually get married come on
out huh have a daughter
eating your own mango tree you'll spend
your whole life creating websites
companies even logos that millions of
people love but none of those will
compare to how proud you are of your
most important creation your family
[Music]
you